Joe Biden's been a big story uh people
he's the front-runner I'm curious what
your take is on Joe Biden yeah I just
think that's another stupid thing of
just because every mouth breather can
chime in it's never about what the
pictures about it's always what's going
on in the corners yeah you landed on the
moon great but what's up with your
helmet you know they always gotta like
trash I like people they just look they
he's an old guy okay he came up in
politics from you shook hands you kiss
babies he was probably standing on the
back of the Train he's so friggin old
and now it's just time pass them by
right so you're just thinking that it
just is a guy who's older he's got a
different style and that people were
making none of the pictures of that
creepy right his hands on someone's
woman's woman's hip right and then you
take the picture and you just start
writing a bunch of creepy [ __ ] about
what he's doing it's not like he went
for side boob he wasn't like like
sliding up no it's a total over he gets
out of the face someone makes when
they're going for side boob Conan's
going for it
be easy to spot you know what it is
they've destroyed so many guys like he's
all that's left now they're going after
like a hundred year old guys my question
is one of they gonna go after the horse
right if we're gonna sit here the hotel
if we're gonna vet everybody when are
they gonna turn it around and start how
many times can you watch a woman who's
never sunk a jump shot
or hear a big putt in her life take some
guys big giant house what why you
looking at me like you don't know what
[ __ ] are [ __ ] Oh divorce I thought
you said the horse no I said oh I said
[ __ ]
you're both wrong I said [ __ ] never
happened before were you and I both
misunderstand yeah yeah that's never
happened in 26 years right you're the
one that's what switched tapas cuz
you're out of control out of control I'm
out of control
I'm just saying this predatory women out
there to do a thing right now go do a
show third show Saturday night in a
comedy club I'm telling you you got a
you got an unhappily married woman in an
under sex marriage after a couple of
drinks okay I'm telling you cover your
junk because she's coming full-court
press with a great team I used to be
able to pick them up you try to get a
table between you and them
you had a full-on breakdown I am NOT you
just not listening I am listening to
every word I'm do your horse was attack
you going after you're going after Joe
Biden for doing like it look I'm not
gonna bite literally us like those pick
when used to get a family photo at Sears
and they they pose it he's he just looks
like he's posing and people I know what
is he doing yeah why is his hand there
did he just sniffer it's like how bored
are you this is why nobody of any like
any reasonable decent human being is
going to run for president because of
you [ __ ]
it is that it's the Millennials the nerd
you're a bunch of rats all you doing is
trying to get people in trouble that's
all you're doing taking pictures and
recording people he said this but did
you really mean that so it's the
Millennials that are making it
impossible for anyone to run for
president right now I get I don't know
what it is like I don't know a job
that's what it was look that was a long
time ago I noticed we're not focusing on
any of the real problems we're bankrupt
we're literally bankrupt you win a
championship you get fast food at the
White House that's how broke we are now
everybody's blaming Trump like you know
like he's got a budget now he doesn't
we're literally bankrupt but nobody's
focusing on that and you know you do any
joke and you stand up act all the
Millennials flip out you know what I
mean they're all hurt yeah of course the
lady with the gray teeth isn't too
pleased right now oh my god does she do
people do women really grab your junk oh
yeah
no those club is this and how can I get
there it's not fun dude it's yeah it's
been a long time yeah this freak